other great game 41 points 11 rebounds
but only four assists what do you make
of that stat what Miami did tonight they
said all right we're gonna make Joker to
score let's take away other people I can
see them in their coaches meetings
saying Murray's the head of the snake
when you play a team you sort of realize
he's going to dominate no matter what we
do so we got this is the head of the
snake and I think they just decided
Murray's the guy we got to stop so you
start love with Jimmy Butler on Murray
there was a point where they like went
to that match-up zone and I was saying
put Jimmy Butler on Murray you keep bam
on Joker having bam with us in Olympics
bam can guard anyone but it keeps those
guys in front now you're not getting the
back door Cuts Joker's not getting 10
assists and it forces everybody to
struggle against every team you know in
the playoffs you're just trying to take
them out of rhythm we always use the
Belichick line you know make them play
left-handed trying to take A team's
strengths take that away and make them
do something